le secteur du bâtiment est en crise
depuis plusieurs semaines les matières
premières se font rare entraînant une
augmentation des prix ah mais raide
entreprise de métallerie tam
cela pose évidemment problème les sujets
que nous avons actuellement
effectivement ce sont les prix les prix
fournisseurs qui ont augmenté en acier
de grosso modo 30 à 40% en inox 70% et
en quincaillerie prix très très variés
puisque nous avons eu quelques hausses
de 10% et quelques lots jusqu'à 50% ce
prix là nous ne pouvons pas les
répercuter à nos clients puisque nous
avons signé des marchés depuis six mois
non et ce sont des prix fermes et non
révisable conséquence des prix qui
s'envolent le risque de pénurie inquiète
aussi le chef d'entreprise
nous avons des produits standards que
l'on ne trouve plus donc on en veut
absolument puisque il nous les faut et
nos fournisseurs nous dise si tu en veux
plus voilà le nouveau prix et qui majeur
la chine et des états unis inspire
énormément de production corp européenne
et nous avons subi effectivement toute
cette matière première ou seebach qu'ils
s'en vont à l'étranger on est deux apu
sur le marché français donc
effectivement on va avoir quelques
soucis cette crise des matières
premières aura des conséquences sur les
futurs chantiers
l'entrepreneur l'assurent il devra
intégrer à ses futurs contrats une
clause supplémentaire sur les prix des
matériaux
le but pour moi maintenant c'est de
prévenir tous les promoteurs immobiliers
avec qui je travaille c'est que
maintenant nous allons revoir nos prix
avec un coefficient de révision nos
marges sont moins bonnes puisque
le prix matières étant plus plus
important peut pas le revendre ensuite
voeux de plein fouet des conséquences
qui vont donc se répercuter sur les
clients la fédération française du
bâtiment estime qu'il n'y aura pas de
retour à la normale avant six mois